[Music]
Miley Cyrus just dropped her new music
video for mother's daughter and it is
jam-packed with some badass women's the
video features a whole host of powerful
activists and members of the LGBTQ
community now we are breaking down who's
who and what they have to say about
finding power and freedom in their own
self-expression
starting with model and actress Angelina
do Plescia after the video dropped
Angelina posted an empowering body
positive and inclusive message to
Instagram that basically said let people
live their lives harassment free quote
don't put their freedom to feel happy
and beautiful right now not just when
society says it's okay next up
eleven-year-old activist
philanthropist and self-proclaimed
future president Mari Copa knee
mari has been fighting against Flint's
water crisis and she was just 8 years
old even gaining the attention of then
President Barack Obama
[Music]
that's dancer actress and activist
Melanie Ciara who founded let's talk
mother an organization that aims to
provide mental and emotional support for
single mothers Miley shared this pic of
Melanie on Instagram quoting her in the
caption my voice is my truth and my
truth is the blood of my art it's the
pulse that allows me to fight for myself
and for others to always be seen and
heard
next up Miley's a longtime dancer Amazon
Ashley
Playboy Playmate Vendela also makes a
cameo Miley shared this pic of her with
the model on Instagram Vendela explained
her signature ball to do in the caption
saying quote I'm not afraid to be Who I
am and not who society says I should be
as a woman I don't conform to the norms
empower yourself even better let's
empower each other 27 year old pro
skateboarder Lacey Baker stands tall in
the video
[Music]
lacy says she's using her platform as an
athlete to help create a space for
marginalized communities there is so
much love to share in the LGBTQ
communities all over the world and to be
able to tap into this love through
skateboarding is so beautiful there's
Aaron Philip an Antigua an American
transgender disabled model who has
already slayed for paper magazine and
ASOS
she says quote as a black girl in a
wheelchair who happens to be trans I
just want to have a good life and do
good in whatever my endeavors consist of
regardless of what that might mean in
the face of oppression I fight for my
freedom by being myself
[Music]
that's trans model Castle MacArthur and
there are dancers tedran Scot and Paige
frolics
[Music]
[Music]
and what were the mother's daughter
music video be without Miley's own mama
Tish Cyrus damn that was a lot of
badassery in 3 minutes and 40 seconds
and I am so here for all of it of course
et will be here to keep you up to date
on all things miley cyrus so be sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hayley Stephens bye for now
[Music]